[Musique]
c'est le grand soir soit pas nerveux
n'aurait pas quelques côté fait pas tout
foiré je t'aime
moi aussi je t'aime on va faire une
fausse et merdiques aller grand sourire
mais le monde jallet samoudi médis a
salué philippe ouah ça fait un sacré
bout de temps
ça doit vous sembler assez étrange que
je débarque comme ça après toutes ces
années
je n'a été qu'un accroc ni la nuit où il
est mort il ya cinq ans
une sorte d'étrange miracle s'est
produit ce bébé qui bouge en moi et
l'enfant de ronnie foule a immédiatement
de ce qu'elle raconte est absolument
impossible de tg s'est pas absolument
impossible
est-ce qu'elle avait l'air bien
pourquoi tu fais ça
[Musique]
revenir aimé que tu veilles sur elle
vous avez toujours eu un truc
c'est beaucoup plus vaste que tout ce
que vous voyez en santé
je ne suis pas folle à lier c'est
vraiment la seule et unique réponse ah
ouais
ça me perturbe
qu'est ce que tu lui as fait richard
tu devais tellement fière de toi et de
ta petite supercherie mais quelle
horreur
si nous connaissions la vérité ce serait
moins effrayant au plus encore
ne pas dire qu'on l'a alors on y va les
tons vert si je résume vous avez chacun
paie 10 euros pour qu'elle vous
enseignent comment pêcher c'est ça c'est
avec moi loi ou mais j'entends pas ouais
elle arrive d2d des tentes et des cartes
hockey un peu trop des terrains
j'ai cru que tu allais morts la seconde
à faire un truc pour votre gueule parce
que vous marchez criblé de balles
ouais c'est de la psychologie
comportementale amoureuse et du coup on
va voir comment vous vous démarquez on
s'assume ans tes lunettes ça fait pitié
ces morts n'a pas la carrure d'un
gagnant mais l'effet de la falémé cause
surtout pas se dire que c'est la meuf
qui s'ouvre
vous avez l'air con les gars qu'on vous
soyez et ben vaut mieux entendre ça que
d'être sourd comme curiosité schluraff
au fond
tu es allé voir une fille de joie non
elle ne touche pas la gueule
[Musique]
m
parfaitement
[Musique]
jeudi 9 juillet love life saison 1
inédite siro csc qui nuit une nouvelle
génération va naître et pour cela nous
avons créé une école spécialement pour
qui tu as lease a ravi deux planètes
[Musique]
soyez très attentifs ça peut vous sauver
la vie tu devras enseigner notre pouvoir
[Musique]
ils auront la possibilité de partager
leur pouvoir de devenir plus fort que
jamais notre micro il arrive des sources
tribales
c'est toi qui tombait pas fait visa mais
qu'est ce que c'est
[Musique]
sitôt mais ne fait pas ça c'est pas toi
on devient de plus en plus forte
elle est différente elle est peut-être
du musée possible mort
que dracula et ce n'est pas tout avec
tout n'est connecté en quelque sorte un
recul à bord
crois moi il est tout ce qu'il ya plus
vivre nous avons à clore pour qui elle
se prend ce n'est qu'une enfant
nous avons vaincu dracula
vous pouvez vous retirer une
il faut qu'on se tienne prêt nous allons
l'étudier comme s'ils n'oublient embêté
mais parce que c'est une carte mur n'est
tue des enfants il ne sommes pas que
deux enfants
et ce pagne et gratuit
[Musique]
bonjour a rien de suspect ah bon pur
vous avez des enfants
oui j'ai une fille de 14 ans quoi c'est
ce que je craignais vous êtes allergique
avant de finir sur ses pas des poux un
nom c'est ma dépouille
je vous souhaite que l'adolescence ne
soit pas à l'éditeur
mais là que tu fous mettre en retard à
l'école j'y vais pas je fais grève hier
à l'école ce qui me laisse sortir
vendredi soir je reste zen
alors bonne journée lille a attenté bien
sorti toi bah oui mais ce pays
moment c'est ma vie qui en dépend et tu
sais que c'est raisonnable et que tu
peux le faire confiance
surprise je vais 14 heures avant toi tu
montes tu fais de toi je serai vigilant
qu'une ado en colère peut-être
imprévisible tu sors avec qui tu rentres
à coeur
[Musique]
tu te fous de ma gueule on parle de ta
fille on danse d'abord comme de merde de
gosses gâtés pourris son nouveau
téléphone tient n'est pas tactile faut
appuyer sur les touches
c'est quoi ça sert tout est sous
contrôle et pas de problème juge air
plus froid qu'ait jury d'être différente
de trois mamans de faire autrement mais
regarde moi
jusqu'à quel âge et reste à dos parce
que moi j'en peux plus vous savez moi
aussi j'ai une adolescente à la maison
et beaucoup de chance ça se passe
extrêmement bien tout va bien ici
oui parce que votre fille libanais quoi
tu payes de près de chez moi
[Rires]
[Musique]
mais claude intérêts
que faire
[Musique]
c'est un marché que fuit leur pays
pauvre petit
[Musique]
ce coup pas mal non là c'est rien
sinon on va y retourner
toutes les familles sont un peu bizarre
mais franchement y'a pas plus bizarre
que la nier mon père c'est big foot
alors c'est quoi la prochaine étape 1
une ligne de vêtements manquent de
basket une descente et j'habitais way le
fameux big foot vous dirai pas quand on
voit comme ça mais moi aussi je suis un
bigfoot la nature passe avant tout le
pétrole vers bas xe tract du pétrole
vert à ces vraiment n'importequoi avec
notre notoriété vous pourriez
l'esthétique tracts avant qu'il ne soit
trop tard
[Musique]
à peine revenu et tu veux déjà repartir
dis moi à quoi ça sert d'être célèbre si
j'essaie pas de rendre le monde meilleur
audrey
s'ils sont vraiment rien à cacher
pourquoi ils défendent l'entrée de leurs
sites avec des gars il faut qu'on l'aide
kitty ça y est ça recommence
on s'attache s'il vous plaît
ce qu'ils appellent du pétrole vers sans
impact pour l'environnement
c'est là que le héros purger son
splendide étalons
[Musique]
or berne non tu prends
c'est pas le moment mua
on va finir ce que tu as commencé tous
les trois ont fait des pancakes
vas-y envoie un peu trop beau or très
bon tu peux rien la loi si tu es un peu
lente
vous reconnaissez ouai mais jp c'est lui
qui fait la marche onéreux ne regarde
jamais un bon jeu merci merci du sommet
pourquoi tu ne vas pas plus pour ça
marche vous c'est à dire nous les revues
et les juifs marché contre le racisme
marchi contre les discriminations
marchés arabes et noirs est juif et j'ai
demandé que demain les noirs et les
arabes
on est des frères ok mais on est des
frères que quand ça vous arrange ses
traits vous évidemment fu chi dans ce
salon laisserait sa soeur se mettre avec
un noir qui tue pas de soeur pourquoi je
veux pas que venir évaluer votre image
vous savez ce qu il vous faut pas une
marche c'est un triathlon voilà au
sénégal
[Musique]
faut que vous soyez invisible comme des
ombres
[Musique]
faut que tu vois à travers les gens pour
ça faut passer des heures dans la rue il
passe ma vie déjà toi ta bonne donc les
on va passer une étape supérieure
cox et éthique à cela deux ballons va
faire de l'argent peut-être un gros jet
pas les couilles avec ta grande gueule
dans trois mois tu es mort non c'est pas
des conneries ce livre c'est une grosse
bosse la tribu tous coupe à l'astuce le
crois pas trop tu proposes moi je
propose trois trophées quoi ça donne je
circulais
[Musique]
tuer quelqu'un
vrai quoi
que je radote en grattant white
irrigants oui jma le tort quand on me
bon père j'avais déjà l'écho avec des
tanks les gens que je m'arrête à temps
brouillé attend oui c'est le club
[Musique]
ce n'est pas un coup
l'as monaco
[Musique]